One kind of educational technology that
people are probably very familiar with
is educational games,
or game based learning.
These are games that are developed
not just to be fun and engaging but
also to teach some material.
I grew up on educational games.
I remember things like
Super Solvers to Operation Neptune.
And they're still some
of my favorite games.
And the real power of those games is
that the learning in those games is very
authentic.
They find a way to take the material
they want you to learn, and
make a game out of that material.
And that's where educational games
can really have a lot of power,
is when they make the real
material itself come to life.
But there can also be a dark
side of game-based learning.
If what we make into the game is
not authentic to the material,
if we just kind of staple on
things like achievements and
badges onto a learning activity.
We risk creating very inauthentic
motivation around that learning
activity.
So when we talk about game based
learning we're really going to focus on
how we can make the authentic parts of
the material come out in an engaging
and fun way.
As opposed to stapling on gaming
conventions just to make the activity
more fun, but ultimately not make
the fun authentic to the material.